John Dean why did you want to write a
book on warren g harding I grew up in
Marion Ohio which is Warren G Harding's
home base that's a wasn't born there but
he came there very early in his life and
he was the big name in town when I was
growing up in fact I my paper route took
me right by his house when I was about
14 years of age how long did you live in
Marion I went off to school shortly
after that to a private school but I was
there about five years and we lived not
far from where the Harding home was and
most of my friends were much longer time
residents of Marion and Harding was
somebody who sort of fascinated
everybody in town because of his his
persona and the high school was named
Warren G Hardy high school there was
this Harding memorial that Hardy
memorial and so and so forth so he's a
major figure in the town and the first
president I really think I had an
awareness of well these books are backed
by x books and also but Arthur slicing
her how did you and Arthur slicing her
get together well Arthur and Ida
lectured on the same group several years
ago it was a group down in Florida in
fact it was right during the Clinton
impeachment proceeding I Arthur gave a
talk about history in general and I
happened to be asked to sort of predict
how the process at work and I had my
years in the Nixon White House actually
read the end of Johnson impeachment
trial ones and at that point we needed
little about impeachment so I I've made
a projection that the house would
probably impeach Clinton but at the
Senate would acquit him so I was on the
record as being fairly prescient on that
so in any way an Arthur and I struck up
a conversation at that point and we had
a nice rapport and i dissented my the I
didn't I don't use a prepared talk when
I speak but I said are you interested in
my materials I'd love to have it and so
we started a little rapport and then I
have
to read put in Publishers Weekly that he
was doing this series on all 42 past
presidents and so I called him and I
said Arthur obviously I I shouldn't do
Nixon but I'm going to surprise you in
asking if I can do one that I don't know
if you've assigned a knot and i said i
went i lived in marion ohio and I've
never thought that Warren Harding really
got a very fair shake by history and I'd
like to do that when he said John you
gotta do it and he encouraged me all of
the way you know it was the series as
you know brian is there they're not full
biographies they're fairly tight and I
did the first draft I went way over the
limit it so it's at the book now is down
to where it's supposed to be about
fifty-five thousand words but i did
about I kind of got into it and I did
about 75 almost 80,000 words in a fairly
polished draft but did it in the way I
can collapse it down to where they
wanted it but Arthur actually didn't
want to cut very much some of the early
life we cut down a little bit but the
material I had in about his presidency
and sort of sorting out some of the
problems that had occurred because
history had given him such a bad shake
when I finished hearth er said John
you've made me rethink Harding and I
think you'll make a lot of other
historians rethink it when was he
president he was president in 1920 and
he died in office in 1923 so how long
was he in how about it about 880 some
odd days with 882 and so that's there's
a number of presidents we know that
haven't made a full term and and so he
was I'm sure would have been reelected
had he stood for re-election he was a
very popular present at the time he died
and he was very beloved in office do I
remember a figure of nine million people
were along the railroad wrap from you
just go back to the east coast you do
when he died in San Francisco he was he
had taken this Western trip up to Alaska
the first
president the United States to go to
Alaska as a matter of fact and he
foresaw the potential of statehood of
Alaska in 1923 when he went up there but
he died in the palace hotel in San
Francisco and when the train brought him
back across the country people lined up
they were in fields they were at
crossings they were hanging off of the
roof tops of buildings and apparently
the most moving thing was that the crowd
would get so clustered and they would be
singing hymns and some of the Hardys
favorite hymns and it was apparently
quite a moving procession across the
country and it hadn't been since Lincoln
had died really that anything had been
quite as emotional then it wouldn't be
until Roosevelt died and of course in
our lifetime when the Kennedy
assassination we all recall how that
impacted our lives but so he had a big
impact and he in judging the president
I've always you know when presidents are
ranked as you know one of the first
lines i say in the book is that he's
considered the worst president of the
united states he really got bashed by
history after he died in office and for
many for initially there was a lot of
very popular works that were overboard
in a sense in praise and then it all
started to turn go back to your days in
marion ohio what what kind of family to
go up in what were your parents doing
yes my father came to marion my father
was a carnegie mellon engineer and he
had worked at firestone for a number of
years and he was an expert at sort of
manufacturing efficiency and he became
the president of a company called marion
products in marion and they made
ventilator windows for ford and
dashboards for ford we haven't had many
later windows in a long time but it was
a manufacturing company and that's what
brought us to marion
and what year would you have come again
this would have been about 1950 that was
one and you were I was I was about 10 11
12 at that time how about 12 mm so what
do you remember about Warren Harding in
those early days well I remember the I
remember the house of course he had we
lived on a side the main drag in marion
ohio is mount vernon avenue and the
harding home is on mont burn and we were
on one of the intersecting streets up
about two blocks from his house he had a
you know it wasn't a huge house but it
was a good-sized house he had been a
time a successful editor he was still
growing but you could build a quite a
nice house in those days for not the
same kind of money that cost today but I
remember I went to junior high school in
Marion and actually still have some
friends that are sort of dispersed and
that last year lost one of my dear
friends who I'd known in Marion in fact
I dedicated the book to his father and
his himself and his mother he actually
said step mother still alive but you you
have you say in your introduction or
some place in the book that you were a
personal friend of the grandkids of as a
Wulfen is it an illegitimate child what
it was was Florence Harding had been
married before she married Warren
Harding and she was married into a sort
of a town rake whoo that's what he
became a fella by name of Pete the wolf
and Pete was their next-door neighbor
she was a cling that was her family name
and her father was a very tough cookie
it might be the best way to describe it
and when she grew up she was a
disappointment to her father when she
wasn't a boy he'd always hope
to having a boy and when when Flossie
came along he sort of raised her like he
might his son rather than a daughter and
she went he was he was a very successful
he was actually the richest man in town
at that era and he had a hardware store
and he took Flossie to the hardware
store and she grew up around men she was
five years older than Warren Harding she
was born in 1860 he was one in 1865 but
at one point she got into an affair and
some of the really the consensus is she
did it because she was trying to escape
from a very domineering father and it
was a common law marriage and she had a
child by this marriage and they'd left
town old man clinging as he's known in
Marion at time wouldn't help support the
child or or his daughter she made her
situation and he wanted her to work it
out and she did and later she was
teaching piano lessons and teaching
Warren Harding's sister piano and that's
where it's believed she first met Warren
when today Mary they married in see that
would have been hopefully this man they
married in her howl was Warren Harding
Warren Harding would have been in his
mid-20s when he got married so what kind
of life did they have in Marion for
those years what were they doing he was
he when after he graduated from college
and went to high school is giving me
what the college at 14 years of age to a
college of no longer exists in Ohio
taught for one year after he got out of
college and was sort of looking for a
career he when he came to Marion he
realized that there was a newspaper for
sale called the Marion star it had been
not a very successful paper it have been
in existence seven years was up in the
sheriff's office for repossession Warren
Harding had loved the newspaper business
as a as a about a 13
year old his father who was a doctor had
apprenticed him to a as a printer's
devil which is sort of a printers
handyman it does the dirty work and lots
of gopher today and he was had a
facility with words and he set type very
quickly for such a young person and the
so he had he had this love of words and
he'd been introduced to the the
newspaper business in college he starts
while he's a senior a paper in iberia
Ohio where the college was located and
it was relatively a successful little
six page paper for two college kids to
start and I've always wondered whatever
happened that paper but anyway he moose
Marion after college his family has
moved there and he teaches for one year
and he finds the star and he says let's
make a go of it he gets a couple friends
together and they raised the three
hundred bucks and dr. Harding the father
signed cosines a note and they get the
paper which really launches his career
he's the oldest of eight he is the
oldest of eight to would would would die
in childhood several he had several
sisters and one brother so you also
write early on about his friend Jim
salts he had a number of friends he he's
a person who collects people all the way
along through his life who become sort
of lifetime friends Phillips is one of
them but what I was getting at is that
the what would be in the age in which he
had he struck up a relationship with
Phillips and wife Kerry Phillips well
Philips wife Phillips married a
who was supposed to be the most
beautiful woman in Marion at the time
she actually wasn't from Marion Phillips
was from Marion and he ran a department
store in Marion and he married Carrie
Carrie was probably she was about ten
years the floor is hiding his junior so
and probably she was about so but menk
about five years younger than Warren
Harding and they met and were just
another couple in Marion and I there
must have been a long sort of burning
relationship because what happens is
Warren goes off and he's elected the
Ohio Senate he gets active in Ohio
politics he the mag give me the
newspaper and the supplement that they
do get successful and he becomes
successful and Florence Harding Falls
Berryhill she has a floating kidney
problem that they thought was ridden to
you know we be moving very little about
medicine and but it would go bad and she
would become bed fast for literally
months on end and her life was tenuous
and it's one of these times when she
became ill Carrie Phillips had just lost
a child and Jim Phillips had had a
nervous breakdown Warren ranges for his
friend to go to battle creek to a
hospital or sanitary there were he had
visited but I'd we think for his heart
but it made the arrangements for his
best friend to go there and meanwhile
Kari reaches out and she's this
attractive woman and they start an
affair that will go on for 15 years
anybody know about it during those years
I think it was pretty well suspected
from the i was able and putting the book
together to talk to a lot of people who
you know know that they're not you know
not of the same generation but through
their families they know a lot of the
facts and they they pretty much say that
it was it was well known it was well
known long before it became public
knowledge it was known when I was
growing up for example and it really
didn't become public knowledge and
widespread knowledge until 1973 when a
fellow by the name of Russell wrote a
book called the shadow a blooming grove
and he got he discovered the letters
from carousel excuse me I'm just good
what year did you eventually move out of
Marion Ohio but I left Marion in 1952
because I went out to private school and
my folks were still there for a while so
you mentioned he was in the state Senate
what was his first elected office and
why did he run for office his first
elective office was to try to become a
county supervisor when he saw that the
race was going to go to by default to a
Democrat and as a young as a Republican
and editor of paper he just thought it
was a no-lose situation he might get
some readers he was a very good speaker
a very fluent speaker and so he ran for
that often lost but he got a larger vote
in that particular Democratic region of
Ohio than anybody previously had he he
was slow to enter politics and his first
really important job was he ran for the
Ohio Senate and was in the Senate for
several terms then what he goes from he
retires in the Senate and really is he
ran to the governor the gubernatorial
race once and was defeated it was a he
didn't want to run the party wanted him
to run he thought of a bad idea that was
a bad idea it was a very divisive time
in Ohio politics one thing I should
mention though that while he was in the
Senate and this is some of the things
that have sort of history's overlooked
with Warren Harding the Ohio Senate
really had a fair amount of corruption
in those days and Warren Harding was not
corrupted he had made a good living he
was a successful businessman long before
he went into politics he lived
comfortably he had a wife who ultimately
made up with her father and so there was
no need to to reach and he
came very respected in Ohio for that
reason alone because they never knew he
was clean and that he was sort of the
go-to guy as somebody who could solve
problems and governors went to him and
what happened so he retires from
politics and plans really just to
continue building the star and being the
editor when he's active in Republican
politics still he'll go he goes to his
first convention Brian as a as a really
19 year old kid who has a pass because
he's bought this newspaper it's most
valuable asset being a free pass for all
the railroads so he goes off to Chicago
and and to the first Republican
convention I feel that's one of the
defining events of his life where he you
know this country boy goes into Chicago
and sees the Blaine was the Republican
nominee and he sees Roosevelt putting
people in the nomination at Theodore
Roosevelt and a lot of the great
speakers Ingersoll and it obviously
catches his fancy but when he comes back
to Ohio yes I say he's not active in he
really gets back into politics when
there's an opening for the US Senate and
those who know him say why don't you
take a run at it he's at this point he's
you know he's matured he's in his early
50s and he decides to take a go at it
and very successfully runs he's an
interesting politician Brian in the
sense that he refuses to in particularly
in primaries to speak ill of other
Republicans he had Ronald Reagan's 11th
commandment long before reagan had made
it to sort of what should be the going
rule so he won't campaign hard against
other Republicans for nomination and
this works people like the fact that
he's not a divisive politician and he's
elected to the Senate
on the first bid you have a milestones
in the back yet we do the dates and when
things have a 1914 elected the United
States it was that direct election or
was that through the legislature that is
a that is the first direct election
that's it 14 no I really I that no that
is a correct election and at that time
and he served in the military at all no
he had not did he have any children well
that's a good question that's a tougher
question is you with a trick question
it's at Sur collection there is a
purportedly he has an illegitimate
daughter I have grave reservations about
this whole situation people in Marion
have grave reservations his family and
he has a family of doctors his father
was a doctor his mother was a doctor his
brother and as a whole line of Harding's
now in fact there is a Warren Harding
the third who have talked to delight the
man who is a doctor in Cincinnati
actually was in Los Angeles and a and
worked for the Dodgers for a number of
years as their physician after going to
UCLA but anyway the question of whether
he has any children the family always
understood that he was sterile and was
in KP love children and would have loved
to have had children we know that
Florence Harding had a child from a
prior marriage so theoretically she
could have had children so that tends to
support the fact that indeed he was
sterile what after he dies a story comes
out that he has this illegitimate
daughter and in fact it really becomes
one of the turning points of his
reputation in 1927 a woman by name of
nan Britton publishes a book called the
president's daughter her name is
Elizabeth Ann and and she in the book
she said Britain says she's never the
father had never met the the child and
that the affair had started in nineteen
19 while he's still in the Senate and
continued while he was into the White
House during the Clinton years has came
up a couple times I have the gravest
doubts about this happening when you
really start getting into some of the
people who had knowledge and it seems to
me much more myth you say in the book
that when the Secret Service supposedly
she says the secretaries interrupted
them in a closet somewhere I White House
I don't believe it the the chief agent
of the fellow bottom of Edmund Starling
denies all this and it it just doesn't
seem possible to me that too many people
while the White House isn't anything
like it is today as far as security and
what have you the best I can tell he is
he is affair with Kerry Phillips last
while he's in the Senate it's handled
discreetly it's never it's just they
fell in love and then there's what
happened is Kerry Philip's War matt
harding to divorce his wife he refused
to do so and that's what breaks up
through the affair and she goes off to
Europe and and has affair with the
Kaiser but as far as nan Britton she's
very much much younger than Warren
Harding and she's really been infatuated
with him since Warren sister was one of
her teachers at high school and she has
his infatuation and I'm convinced as I
put the piece together what happened is
that Kerry Phillips daughter and nan
Britton were friends because the letters
that Harding had written which would
later appear and will lob there in the
library of congress now they won't be
released until 2010 they've been sealed
up but i think that nan Britton saw
those letters because Kari kept them and
the carries daughter and her mother were
estranged and I think the man sort of
adopted Carrie's story
and made it her own and then created
this whole myth one last question on
this did you try to track down Elizabeth
and relatives elizabeth anne i believe
is still alive today and I've actually
been talking to Warren Harding the third
about this I actually know where there
is DNA today but I didn't want to do a
DNA test to resolve it until I had the
permission to both Elizabeth Ann or her
family and warren harding the existing
one hottie or this brother George also
have the permission of both this is
Elizabeth Ann had the last name that you
know that I do it Sidon I mentioned it
in footnote in the books give me i was i
was able to track her for the reason to
privacy i'm not going to throw her name
out because I people look at the book i
think is a little different but I I
think it would be a great mystery to
resolve but she may well not want to
know the paternity issue and I was able
to track her to glendale california and
find that she popped up in 1964 and gave
an interview with the LA Times I then
went to sort of the the basic records
and the telephone directories and what
have you and followed them till eight
until nineteen seventy I was able to and
then they all sort of disappear and it's
a very unusual spelling on the name so I
i get i gave up i was spending too much
time trying to track this down but what
happened as i had a conversation with a
lawyer friend here in town or in
Washington and we I was telling him
about this this wonderful mystery to be
nice to solve and I said I've actually
talked to people and about DNA testing
and paternity and it's a very simple
test you just have to do a swot on the
cheek and you can do it credit quickly
and it's very inexpensive and I thought
it'd be a great mystery to resolve and
solve that problem and he said well I
have
one of the law firms that we work with
we do a lot of state work have missing
air search capabilities and do you want
me to try and I said sure well we found
all of them so I know where all
Elizabeth and her sons her daughter's
three children did you say I think she
has I don't know for sure how many
children she has at least she had two
sons and possibly a daughter and I
believe she's living with her daughter
right now and she would be how old in
her 80s and rabies so if she happens to
catch this broadcast maybe she'll come
forward on her own I don't want to force
the issue it's sort of an invasion her
name has been mentioned by students of
the subject that we could resolve a
question very simply today that we
couldn't years ago let me stop from I'm
going to ask you about how you went
about this how long did you work on this
book I I had a unique situation I have
probably in my library about everything
that's been written about Harding's just
one of those after a very early
conversation with my next-door neighbor
who happened to become the editor of the
Marian star which was Harding's paper he
kind of got my attention and I started
reading about him very young and so what
I did to work on the book is I had to
reread a number of books the the best
books one of the risk of me let me go
wall are you back on this to give you a
little background the reason history got
so astray on harding is that it was long
believed that his presidential papers
had been burned by Florence Hardy she
did get a box and she did burn some but
actually what had happened is his
secretary had been with him in the 72
male secretary who'd been a longtime
family friend as well had all of his
Senate papers and then took all of his
presidential papers and put them in the
basement of the White House and they
were there until nineteen twenty nine
when they were discovered during the
Hoover administration and they were all
sent off to Marianna
aisle just for a moment he died what
year again 23 so they were there for six
years in the base yes yes and then they
go they're shipped off to Marion and
they stay in the basement of the Higgs
house but I was bicycling by that house
there were all those presidential papers
no one ever opened and finally in 1964
the as they were approaching the
hundredth anniversary of this of his
life if you will the Ohio Historical
Society convinced that those who had
control of the papers for the Harding
Association to put them and make them
available if they would process them and
give them archival treatment and what
have you so that was when they became
available and only really two historians
Brian have really worked sort of it with
public editions of from those papers
robert murray is one fellow buddy with
Sinclair a British guy and Andrew
Sinclair did a fast study Murray is the
best general biography and he did a
follow-up work as to how Harding
affected the the Coolidge administration
and what what I found and I there are a
few microcut microfilm editions of the
papers I found one at Cal State Hayward
which was as close as I could get on my
side of the Mississippi to set of the
papers so I used those extensively
excuse me because I'd never had a chance
to look at them in all these years and
then there were a couple secondary works
that had been very good but the best
source is I went to the PhD
dissertations who'd been done after 64
and they had all been based on the
papers and they became a nice key for me
to get into the papers and there
unfortunately only one of them is
published but the unpublished ones so I
used those to get into doing this work
but from the time you had your
conversation with mr. slicing her till
the time you finished it what was that
about eight months and that where she
went through your research what was done
most useful to you and besides what
you've told us here to understanding
this guy and why do you conclude that he
wasn't our worst president a couple
things I had never looked he put
together a very remarkable cabinet he
had Charles Evans Hughes who would later
be was on the Supreme Court and then
left the Supreme Court when he ran for
president and then went back on the
Supreme Court one of the finest minds on
the court Wilson beat him yes Charles
Evans yes yes and then used wood as I
favor returned to the court and serve
great distinction so when I read his
biography as a two-volume biography he
talks about Harding because he was
secretary of state for Harding he was
observed that he's the senior member of
the cabinet and he would give the eulogy
in Congress and at the time he wrote his
I read this in the biography of his
there was still thought that he was
presidential timber and would run for
president and that he should sort of
back off a little bit because some of
the corruption that occurred during the
Carter years in the VA administration
Veterans Administration and Harry
Daugherty would would have some problems
none of this ever really involved
Harding himself he was he was on he died
before all has happened he is tagged
with teapot dome which occurs after he's
dead he's not involved in any corruption
that there's any sign of in my
estimation and and many other historians
would look closely at it but so cart
know so so use his aides are telling him
don't be too good to Harding in this
eulogy and you says listen what I have
to say about Warren Harding I know
firsthand and it's a wonderful eulogy
it's a it's a very honest eulogy he
Florence Hardy would write him and say I
couldn't change the sentence in what you
said and you said that he had based this
on the man he
to the man he'd worked with they had a
very successful major disarmament
conference I think what if historians
really start mining this area and the
newspapers would have more on this I've
not had time to ever look at those that
there is this we have another hidden
hand presidency like Eisenhower was
later discovered to be much more
involved Warren Harding was thought to
be sort of lazy and lackadaisical not
true here's a man who's had tremendous
self-confidence entire life he's a man
who succeeded by not trying to get
himself out in front he's a man who does
not to his own horn he has he really
becomes president by sort of under
running rather than over running and I
think that you saw this quality and in
him and realized now this is a fine nine
this is a good man he'd done a nice job
after Wilson it was a very turbulent
time we were in the aftermath of World
War one Wilson us has a strike a stroke
at the end of his presidency so the the
nation really is adrift when when
Harding comes in the economy's in
trouble and he's a heart he's also a
much by Wilson Center is a very
progressive president 1920 he was
elected first before we get to the
election how did he get the nomination
the first place from the Republicans
where was the convention held how many
ballots were there and who were I think
he said it was like nine candidates
there were Hardy has always been
considered a dark horse candidate who
was put there by the cabal of senators
not so in it did the famous smoke-filled
room story came around Harding didn't
happen that way when you look at hardees
correspondence you know he's playing
Hardy was poker player and played those
cards very close and love poker paid
played serious every game you played was
a was a good poker game and those word
in the Senate you know he was he was a
favorite player because it was good good
player and one more than he lost but he
played his nomination very much the same
way held the cards very close
do what he had and how to play his hand
and he authority came up with a very
interesting scheme of running with be
sort of in the back of the pack and
everybody else would destroy themselves
by the time they got to the convention
or during the convention and then there
would be an opportunity for somebody to
be the peacemaker and that's how hard he
would get the nomination they would go
through several ballots where he would
not even be in play and then slowly the
already released his you know his
balance he had at the convention because
these were not primaries had just
started you had just gone into direct
elections in the primaries and the
bosses were having less and less
influence so you really had a very
legitimate convention in those days how
big did he win by and who did he beat
1920 he would have been what 55 yeah he
he his principal candidate in the there
was a fellow by the name of a soldier by
the name of leonard leonard leonard
woods right was the leading person and
woods would appear in uniform at every
primary thing and he had most of the big
money behind him federal bellingham of
from the Procter & Gamble money had been
behind him and he threatened Harding in
Ohio in a primary which really kind of
annoyed Warren Harding because he's not
about Leonard what is it as a Republican
yes I was getting to the Democrat oh oh
yes oh he ran he ran against the
Governor of Ohio I'm sorry just a
polished jim caviezel cox right and with
Roosevelt as his running mate Franklin
Roosevelt as his running mate and Cox
was the ohio governor and a good
governor and harding ran one of these
campaigns were again he understates this
case he doesn't get nasty he actually
runs in a sense against Wilson's
policies rather than than against Cox
because cot what Cox had done coxon
Roosevelt had gone back to Wilson after
they had gotten the nomination and said
we will run on the League of Nations we
will make that the issue and that had
been something that Harding had been on
the fence about in the Senate and
decided that's a good campaign issue you
say 16 million votes for Harding 9
million votes for Cox yes it was a
largest landslide at that time in
history Republican and Democratic House
and Senate I mean republican senate and
house yes good good coattails so not too
dissimilar from what George Bush's not
well it was the the in a sense that
there was one party in the control yes
but the the Senate was much more
Republican and they had much more depth
these are the present Congress is fairly
well tightly balanced Herbert Hoover was
his commerce secretary Andrew Mellon his
Treasury secretary john davis at labor
Albert fall and interior Harry Daugherty
at justice did they call him also
Daugherty no they do that where was the
Daugherty named you remember that in
history I don't and then Edwin Denby at
Navy you know before we talk about what
happened in the cabinet after he died
and left what were his big
accomplishments I'd say the largest
accomplishment was his 1921 disarmament
conference it was a major event the
there had been some effort in the Senate
to to have such in a conference take
place Harding who was purportedly
supposed to be from the Senate and the
cabal of the Senate told the Senate I
will do this on my terms when I'm ready
and he and Charles Evans Hughes worked
this out and it went very successfully
it was a remarkably successful
disarmament conference at the time they
got the reduction of capital ships
substantial and a fair balance between
the Brits and the US and then the
Japanese were the other major power at
the time
so it was and he really kind of pegged
his foreign policy on you know bringing
back and because the nation was weary
from war it had been an unpleasant war
and it was very time before that was met
with his major foreign accomplishment in
domestic his most lasting one he created
the Bureau of the budget in 1920 when he
first got there it had been rejected
they'd been talk of it by prior
presidents Wilson had rejected it which
is kind of interesting a political
scientists like Wilson who had studied
the Congress so many years before even
became a elected official had didn't
like the way the legislation had been
created but Harding believed that he'd
been in the Senate so he knew that was a
need for a good operation for the budget
but as you point out in the book about
the budget that he wanted a billion
dollars reduced the budget now back in
nineteen twenty one or so that would
that's huge that's trillions by today's
standards so he did a major cutback in
spending and he brought in a fellow by
name of Dawes who would later become a
vice president who this was when he was
the first director of the Bureau of the
budget and does they had a series of
conferences over at the Department of
Commerce's auditory and they brought
them in and all the senior civil servant
people the supervisor level and above as
well as the cabinet and Harding to put
out an order that he wanted everybody to
come and he went to the first one and
DAWs got up there and and he did a sort
of a show-and-tell at one point he had
two brooms in his hand and he said he
said this broom cost X dollars whatever
it was at the time and this broom cost y
dollars which was much more expensive
and he explained how that the military
the Navy had these and the army had the
others and while the Navy had a surplus
the army had gone out and purchased all
these other broom
the excess cost rather because it didn't
like the binding around the top of the
straw so he said this this is never
going to happen again we're now going to
be a much more efficient government and
it made a point in fact does he took
when he left he took his broom and he
took the sign on his door which was a
cardboard written sign Bureau of the
budget he refused to even have a printed
sign made for the office you say he came
back as vice president for Coons yes for
Supreme Court justices in 800 days yes
that doesn't you know what Jimmy Carter
didn't have it in four years and how big
an impact did those four justices have
very large impact he would put Taft on
as Chief Justice Taft was a former
president at that point he would put
justices who rank who stood the test of
time well he I think that the Taft
appointment is probably the most
important and intact people don't
realize how much rapport there often is
between a president and a chief justice
as to the future appointments for
example Richard Nixon had long
conversations with Warren Berger about
who to select and and what have you and
I'm sure that bill Rehnquist might well
be having discussions about of that
nature because I think of Chief
Justice's a you know it had to bridge
the constitutional separators at some
point so he's during his presidency just
to recap a little bit he had come from
the Senate he's only one of two
presidents that have come from the
satellite John Kennedy being the other
one he's in the White House he's got
several have wanted to yeah but he's in
the White House for only a little more
than 800 days was he sick while he's in
the White House at all Florence Harding
was very ill and I think that that he
was not physically in any way
debilitated while he was in the White
House he had a we now know he had a bad
heart he had a bad heart all of his life
and this effect
his he had a house dr. white house
doctor who one point after he came back
from a very bad bout with the flu sent
him to Florida in fact one of the things
that Hardy has been accused of is being
in being lackadaisical was that he would
go out and play golf three days a week
well this was actually prescribed by his
doctor in the way Harding played golf he
almost made an aerobic sport I was able
to find some people actually knew how he
played and they said no one wanted to
play with him l didn't when he because
he was president he was literally you
know another important factor I think a
telling factor for me anyway I I played
competitive golf as a kid and I've
always said you could tell an awful lot
about a person by playing 18 holes with
them and as their character well Warren
Harding took the lies exactly where they
lie no Mulligan's made people said no no
get taken out he refused he played
exactly by the rules but he paid very
quickly he would he would shoot him and
he would walk very quickly to the next
shot so he actually would get his heart
rate up because he knew he had to take
exercise we'll talk about that period
again when he was present would any of
the in the illegitimately was any of
that in public and no time no it all
came out afterwards was there anything
about the scandals that happened after
he died in public at that time the only
one that came up at all while he was
alive was the Veterans Affairs scandal
where the man he'd appointed over there
was just over there bilking the place he
was selling off surplus supplies and
when Hardy learned of it he called him
over to the White House and one to know
and he was lied to and then he finally
fired him for insubordination as soon as
he had heard the real problem the only
time in the book that we get any hint of
your past connection with anything is
when you have a little parenthetical
expression you say the most scandal
before Watergate well I met a referenced
the reference I made is that my interest
in warren harding was not because of
Watergate a subject about which I have
more knowledge than I might wish I
head butt and that the fact that teapot
dome excuse me that Watergate had
certainly surpassed teapot dome as the
leading scandal of the 20th century and
that's the only reference I made to it
how much does 30 years later yes
Watergate impact your life anymore well
it obviously had a devastating impact on
my life when it happened it was a very
maturing experience that Hal we I was in
my early 30s when it when it happened
and you during that time went to prison
for a couple months I actually
technically never went to present I I
had I was in the witness protection
program they're worried about keeping me
alive at the time and so I was in a safe
house and then spent most of that time
actually in the prosecutor's office and
it was 120 days that I was sort of in
confinement when but i actually had i
was in the witness protection program
for over a year he ever by the way to
get a pardon never did and when you look
back on on me as you deal with history
here and you're reading about this
scandal did that bring back all those
experiences well it I Ryan one of the
things I think we don't handle well and
don't understand well are the mechanics
of scandal and because of Watergate I
got very interested in it I've watched
them in fact though the time I spent the
most time in Washington since Watergate
was actually during the Clinton
impeachment proceeding when I was
working for MSNBC here in this building
spent I was back here for three months
at that point I I have sort of taken an
academic look at scandal and there's
very little academic study now yes there
everybody recounts how they happen and
you have the historical take of the
legal take or the morality or the ethics
issues but nobody looks at sort of the
way the anatomy of a scandal and I've
been gathering information for years and
may well do a book on this someday
because we don't understand them and
there's a very clear pattern where
I and today a scandal does not happen if
the media does not react they all their
mediated events today you have to have a
reaction and a negative reaction and
that controls whether you have a scandal
where do you live today I live in
California in Los Angeles whatever
happened to Maureen Dean Maureen Dean is
living with me in Los Angeles how long
have you been married we've been married
now for three decades have you had
children I have a child by the first
marriage and where is that child he's in
Pittsburgh when 23 with free
granddaughters I and when you did this
particular book and you got to the
scandal part of it what did you find you
know we mentioned this earlier what did
you find and how it related to any
possible wrongdoing for Warren Harding
well I think because of my own
background experience I wanted to make
sure this man had a fair shake and I
think that's true with with any
president they do I was very interested
in how the myth of misbehavior had grown
up around Harding and when I began I
didn't want to pick a fight with
historians as I told Arthur but I would
track down their sources and I would
find it was third hand here say at best
it was being relied on on some of these
things and I just didn't think this is a
fair way to treat a presence so that
that's how in a sense i said i want at
least what i would say would be
admissible evidence in court to even
make sort of a prima facie case and a
lot of historians don't have that level
of requirement in their critical
thinking who did eventually go to jail
and who lost their jobs he but in a
hardened administration there were only
the head of the Veterans Administration
and a one other person there were two
people that went to jail in the hardy
administration now you had one just
Smith who was probably up to his
eyeballs in this behavior but he
committed suicide you had the other
rather descript
version thats it was proud he was pretty
brutal what he did is hang his head over
a wastebasket and blow his brains out
yes that's the best best situation and
in a very curious situation another man
who had worked with in the involvement
in the Veterans Administration scandal
had actually bought the Harding house
here when in over on wyoming avenue and
he committed suicide to their I remember
named ain't one of the names Forbes
right was he the one boards was the head
of the of the of the VA and then Albert
fall was now that was that happens after
Harding's death in fact I spent
yesterday at the National Archives
because I'm very fascinated with teapot
dome I I I take a in fact I was looking
at the book this morning and I I'd
called fall a bad apple and I began to
think after I'd published the book I
thought about that is that really fair
because fall went to prison for bribery
he was purportedly bribed by a fella by
name of doheny an oilman and sinclair
both sinclair and doheny were acquitted
of bribing his fall was was also a part
of a conspiracy case he was not indicted
and that as the case goes along and he
gets older and he gets me very ill he's
finally convicted of bribery and I
thought it might might be interesting to
go through that trial record and see how
it holds up today and so I actually went
out and started through it yesterday so
I could send some student and do some
copy in for me because I'm just kind of
fascinated to look at that scandal it by
the way I don't know I'm asking this was
it that there's a del Heaney street or
avenue I've seen it when I've been out
in California near where you live I live
in Beverly Hills I do is that the same
donated same Doheny it was he well he
was he was an oilman he struck it he was
actually a friend of Albert Falls they
had both tan
go for gold before in New Mexico and
then he fall had become very successful
businessman in New Mexico and had been
very instrumental in bringing the new
mexico into statehood and came back and
represented New Mexico in the Senate
that's where he met Warren Harding now
Doheny had gone off and continued
prospecting and looking for oil and
struck it in California and became one
of the wealthiest men in the nation at
that time and he was the one who he did
a deal with fall and fall all we said
that he had borrowed a hundred thousand
dollars from Doheny because they were
old friends which was true and he was
short and he had told Hardy when he went
into the cabinet I'm really this is
really a stretch for me I'm I need to
get back to work and he would fall was a
very successful corporate lawyer and had
had had big clients and it just doesn't
seem right to me that he would be so
stupid to take a bribe and it's so
conspicuously so I think that's why I
want to relook at the at the case I get
the impression from reading the book
that you like the fact that you were
painting Warren Harding as a progressive
reason anti just a second but that leads
me to want to ask you after you served
for rich in Richard Nixon's White House
where are you politically today when I
went back to California I registered it
as an independent even when I worked for
richard nixon i had never voted a
straight ticket I'm i am probably a
physical conservative and somewhat of a
of a social moderate to liberal and
that's pretty much way it's always been
do you by the way and we only have a
Minnesota you talk to anybody that what
you were ever associated with in the
Watergate year many of the people I was
associated with has anybody said
anything to you in the later years that
hey I thought you were wrong back then
but I've learned sensitive on target I
have had some people when the tact of
the tapes came out some people have said
John you know we know now better what
you went through do you make any efforts
to listen
those tapes I I did a book called the
the rehnquist choice and that was the
most intense listening I had done and
they were fascinating because I in those
tapes i heard Nixon in his best I also
heard him it is worse what do you think
he'll end up in history he'll be haunted
by the tapes throughout his his history
and you know it and it's a shame because
he had obviously made those never
anticipating that they would be made
public they were very private
conversations and he's got his guard is
down but he you find you know he this is
not the man who we were used to seeing
on stage and what have you I began to
see him as I went on as counsel and he
got relaxed with me and became more open
and candid but it's looking backward you
put Richard Nixon above or below Warren
Harding as well I have problem ranking
presidents I think it's unfair to rank
them we don't have a good criteria for
ranking president figured that out
because I've talked a lot of historians
have been involved in ranking and they
have real good knowledge of some
presidents they have very little
knowledge of others but yet they rank
Harding got ranked at the bottom because
very few people really knew much about
him other than the bad history Nixon you
know Nixon has the potential for being
ranked very high in foreign affairs and
very low for some of his his character
issues that will public haunt him it's a
short book it's a series of books on
presidents that was edited by Arthur
Schlesinger our guest has been John W
Dean here's the cover of the book and
it's all about warren g harding thank
you very much thank you